ve la ricordate la pubblicità delle tabù
immagino di sì visto che ha
traumatizzato milioni e milioni di
bambini degli anni 90 con quella che
pensavamo fosse una creatura nascosta
nell'ombra ma è la terra semplicemente
un cantante che cantava il testo della
pubblicità del tabù trattata tabù anche
bianco non so se lo sapete che ispirata
ad un artista chiamato al joelson
cantante jazz degli anni 20 che con la
sua voce la sua musica ha ispirato
l'intero mondo
ma c'è un altro modo con cui viene
conosciuto al johnson
ebbene il king bella blake face ecco qui
volevo regalarvi una notte insonne un
piccolo incubo per stasera è fare in
modo che questo deal tono all'inter
unico
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ormai con internet non si può più dire
niente o questo è quello che dice e
pensa la gente a causa di quello che
viene definito il politically correct
cioè levitare potenzialmente qualsiasi
tipo di offesa verso chiunque non so
quale sia la vostra posizione in merito
io di solito stop sopra a me piace
osservare tutto quello che succede tutti
questi cambiamenti molto molto veloci e
non penso che tu non possa più dire
niente ormai con internet ei social bla
bla bla
io penso che tu possa dire quello che
vuoi devi essere pronto a pagarne le
conseguenze e con questi cambiamenti
velocissimi e da osservatore esterno mi
piace notare nei film nei telefilm nei
programmi televisivi in giro per strada
tutti queste tutte queste cose tutte
queste frasi che in questo periodo
potrebbero far storcere il naso la
classica frase fatta in questa cosa non
avrebbero mai potuto dirlo oggi come
oggi e andando a scavare nella mia
memoria ne trovo sempre di più la prima
che mi viene in mente sempre ogni volta
che lo riguarda è la scena di arnold in
fantozzi
dove parlano dell'allora attore
protagonista di questa sitcom affetto da
nanismo dicendo semplicemente
di queste frasi francese sono una marea
mi vengono in mente anche pezzettini di
vecchi spettacoli teatrali di maurizio
battista oggi vantare da sempre amato ea
non sapresti 2 la nonna sembrano [ __ ]
antico ma
non per forza frasi anche sono
comportamenti un po particolari che
adesso susciterebbero il delirio nei
social come raimondo vianello in casa
vianello che ci provava con qualsiasi
cosa avesse una vagina e che non fosse
sua moglie dopo di dragon ball 2 dopo
vedrà io non avevo mai associato allo
stereotipo di una persona di colore ma
quando me l'hanno detto del riesco più a
vedere altro ma da così nato esattamente
questo video vigilia di natale 2021 sto
guardando spulciando il catalogo di
disney plus in cerca di qualche
cortometraggio di anni 30 e 40 di natale
da guardarmi becco papà natale 7 minuti
di pura magia natalizia disney se non
l'avete mai visto guardatelo ci sono
delle scene che sono impressionanti da
vedere adesso ma prima di iniziare esce
fuori una cosa che io non avevo mai
visto prima un enorme disclaimer questo
programma include rappresentazioni
negative e o trattamenti errati nei
confronti di persone culture è un
disclaimer per contenuti razzisti io non
l'avevo mai visto e ho scoperto che c'è
ne gli aristogatti in in aladin e in
tutte le cose che già sapevamo e avere
dei connotati un po dubbi ma la parte
che mi ha incuriosito di questo
disclaimer è quella subito dopo invece
di rimuovere questo contenuto vogliamo a
metterne l'impatto dannoso trarne
insegnamento e stimolare il dialogo per
creare insieme un futuro più inclusivo
quindi non vogliamo togliere la parte
razzista ma la vogliamo far tenere per
insegnare alle persone che si è stata
fatta questa cosa qua e no non viene più
fatta e io sono d'accordo sia per
preservare l'intero contenuto così come
è stato pensato ma anche come appunto
insegnamento però scatta in me la
curiosità di chiedermi seduto sul divano
col telecomando in mano quale sarà la
scena secondo me quale sarà la scena che
ha fatto mettere il disclaimer
soprattutto in una cosa come papa natale
che non ho mai visto prima quindi mi
metto comodo sul divano è
concentratissimo e iniziò a formare
questi sette minuti in modo minuzioso
vedo una bambola che fanno spaventare
con un ragno per legarle i capelli no
forse non è quello magari sono queste
bambole palesemente cinesi potrebbe
potrebbe e loro sono lì a chiedermi ma
chissà cosa sarà poi a un certo punto i
giocattoli piano piano camminando
entrano in un enorme sacco di regali ed
è lì che appaiono loro questa banda di
marionette estremamente stereotipate di
persone di colore e da persona che ha
visto le peggio cose online devo dire
che mi ha fatto molto ridere e ho
pensato sarebbe molto figo fare quasi
una caccia al tesoro una caccia al
tesoro di tutte le scene particolarmente
razziste omofobe
maschiliste che ci sono state nell'arco
della vita e ogni volta che qualcuno
dice una cosa potenzialmente sbagliata
nel 2022 in uno showroom in una serie tv
in una canzone immediatamente nella mia
testa a parte un immaginario drink in
game dove devo ogni volta
e molto spesso avrete sentito dire che
il contesto in cui viene detta una
determinata cosa è molto importante per
capirne il peso per capirne il contenuto
la taratura le parole in linguaggio
soprattutto sono cambiate tantissimo nel
corso degli anni e ci sono una marea di
citazione che si potrebbero fare per
spiegare il concetto del contesto
l'errore è pensare alle parole come
entità dipendono per la loro forza è
anche per il loro significato da
associazioni emotive e sfumature
storiche e derivano gran parte del loro
effetto dall'impatto dell'intero
passaggio in cui si verificano ed è qui
che entra a gamba tesa non lo felice
perché karim ci parli di nonno felice
beh prima di tutto perché io ho preso
ormai l'impegno di recuperarmi tutte le
sedi italiane di questo periodo e anche
di periodi che vivevo quando ero molto
più piccolo come casa vianello appunto
il mio professore mare fuori operazione
vacanze e in questo caso non felice il
cui protagonista era uno di quei
personaggi che alla televisione italiana
manca da morire
uno era corrado l'altro e gino bramieri
uno degli showmen
barzellettieri attore comico come ce n'è
uno ogni miliardo di anni come
raccontava le barzellette lui non le
raccontava nessuno ha scritto anche una
marea di libri è nel 1992 è protagonista
di una sitcom chiamata giorno felice di
cui e pochi se lo ricordano hanno fatto
un sequel chiamato norma è felice in cui
lui era affiancato da frank a lei
mammamia dimenticatissimo una grande
mancanza nella televisione italiana
classica sitcom televisiva italiana
molto familiare molto calorosa
rilassante dove lui è un nonno che abita
ancora con il figlio con la moglie del
figlio tratto il film interpretato da
franco oppini che tiene a dirci in
questo periodo che scopa tantissimo con
la nuova moglie
grazie mille franco e vivono appunto
tutti insieme non genitori e due gemelle
e un bambino io vorrei semplicemente
parlarvi dei primi tre episodi
i primi tre episodi è visto come partito
questo video ci sarebbe qualcosa da
raccontare e tra l'altro se volete
vedere le puntate di non lo felice
dall'estero c'è sempre nord di pm che vi
aspetta poi ma ne parliamo dopo non
voi comunque le cose che vi sto per
raccontare immaginate delle in
sottofondo mentre io sto facendo altro e
ad un certo punto ho dovuto fermare
tutto e guardare in modo concentrato
perché non volevo perdermi neanche una
virgola e appena ho aperto il primo
episodio la cosa che più mi ha colpito è
stata la sigla
federico il nipote fa a botte a scuola
perché l'inter è una squadra di brocchi
e stato lui a cominciare ha detto che
l'inter ha una squadra di brocchi
risultato la squadra lui si arrabbia e
quindi iniziano a menarsi e ovviamente
non lo felice che per tutte le puntate
non fa altro che belle grappa e felice
che suo nipote abbia vinto veri ha
picchiato un suo compagno scemo e anche
come la maestra è costretta addirittura
ad andare a casa loro per parlare con i
genitori e da lì iniziano i primi
piccoli segnali dell'età di questa
sitcom perché non lo felice è nascosto
in camera con federico e spia la maestra
dal dallo spioncino della porta tra
l'altro un palese cartonato davanti a
all'inquadratura e fanno i commenti poco
felici
il giornale la tacchini e per essere una
maestra della scuola per capponi era una
bella gallinella federico rischia di
essere sospeso e inizia a piangere e il
nonno lo rincuora dicendogli federico è
che cosa sono queste lacrime la
femminuccia mascolinità tossica
felice per sistemare la questione si
finge parente del bambino picchiato un
po per a parare tutto quanto uno dei
cavalli di battaglia di gino bramieri
era quello di travestirsi da donna in
questo caso una nonna piemontese del
bambino picchiato lei e la moglie
dell'architetto
morire architetto so.re.sa scusi tanto
lavoro scambiata per la cameriera
siamo sul borderline se non fosse che
noi a un certo punto se ne approfitta
allungando le mani sulla maestra lasci
che la braci mi aggiornati che l'ombra
non vedo il caso voglio dire la verità
io mezz'ora che ne vedo riconosce
si conclude la prima puntata
abbastanza bene ma ci sono dei piccoli
segnali di età infatti la seconda
puntata inizia a bomba
[Musica]
non lo felice racconta i nipoti di adamo
ed eva e dei loro figli caino ed abele e
caino era molto geloso di abele perché
lui era brutto sporco e gradino mentre
era bello biondo alto è un po
così come non felice così così così e
quella non battuta lì finisce non
continua non è quello l'argomento della
puntata e non a quelli che hanno mai più
così così
omofobia
il vero argomento della puntata e
l'educazione sessuale sa bene felice
scopre che federico fa finta di studiare
in realtà sta guardando il poster di una
donna l'uva che ovviamente si intasca
tela infilata
seduti sul divano guardando la scena di
un bacio in un film partono le classiche
domande dei bambini che cosa stanno
facendo la respirazione bocca a bocca
quanto dura albace fanno solo quello con
annessi i consigli del nonno che
sicuramente non avranno ripercussioni
sul resto della puntata ma si mangia
tanto avere una bambina sarà un bacio
così
entrano già detto no ne sono sicuro
subito dopo la scena del bacio parte il
classico documentario sull'accoppiamento
delle gruppi attendono l'estate è la
stagione più calda per accoppiarsi cazzo
ma su un curioso per io non credo di
aver mai visto l'accoppiamento delle gru
e la situazione peggiora
[Musica]
e poi tra un film con un bacio
lunghissimo è un documentario
sull'accoppiamento delle gru cosa
potrebbe mai partire ed ora per i nostri
gentili telespettatori trasmetteremo il
nuovo spettacolo di moana pozzi ma
scusami
subito dopo dice che sono le cinque di
pomeriggio
cinque
ma lo spettacolo di moana pozzi alle
cinque di pomeriggio ma che cazzo di
palinsesto c'era nel 92 ma poi cos'è uno
spettacolo di moana pozzi al film o
above un live show di quelli nei club
privè che cazzo e come se non bastasse
l'accoppiamento dei gorilla con una
televisione di in genere poi ti vengono
i dubbi su come cazzo abbiamo fatto a
crescere in questo modo che tu alle
quattro e mezza esce da scuola accendi
la televisione ci sono moana pozzi
gorilla che scopano probabilmente anche
insieme in contemporanea franco oppini a
questo punto non è l'idea
evito una bambina baciandola con
veemenza e lei ha dato una raffica di
pugni o guarda è arrivata la
ripercussione della scena di prima per
cercare di aggiustare il povero federico
che poverino voleva solo guardare una
donna nuda chiamano addirittura una
sessuologa a casa che purtroppo però
odia gli uomini ma io non ho mai detto
no no e neanche lo voglio figuriamoci
adesso mi tiro dentro in casa un oro
iniziano a litigare due dei pazzi e
viene malamente cacciata di casa e
l'episodio finisce col nonno felice la
mattina dopo che dice di aver dormito
poco perché fa intendere che tutto quel
parlare di sesso lo abbia
tenuto sveglio tutte le scorsi che
avevano fatto sette giorni ho sognato
troppo alta e con l'immagine mentale di
gino bramieri che si masturba sotto le
coperte di notte possiamo passare al
terzo episodio
certo
con i colori che parlava in tv e ci sono
stati esempi di nepi straordinaria ecco
io qualche volta penso che in siano
meglio di noi non chiamarli però è come
devo chiamare gli uomini di colore
non è che cambiandoli 9 chiamando gli
uomini di colori cambiamo il colore cosa
sempre presto anche questo per le rose
ipocrisia inutili o porca put a
giro che così duro c'è quello che dice
io non ci volevo credere
non è colpa mia ma poi è una cosa che va
contestualizzata quella di nonno felice
è una cosa che va contestualizzata usare
quel termine per definire il colore è
una cosa molto molto comune ed è per
quello che lui dice quella frase lì a
parte il fatto che vedere franco oppini
poveraccio che gli avevano regalato
dicendomi ma non chiamarli così per
cortesia non
risvegliati basta grappa e parte una
sfilza di imbattute stereotipate sui
neri che non ha più infine scusa minuto
1 scusami non è colpa mia giuro
e così che le facevano vedere non così
che le faccio vedere per domencia su
censurando le parole di un crimine
questa cosa fa praticamente si ammalano
le due gemelle e chiamano il dottore ma
il dottore non c'è quindi arriva il
sostituto che è nero il problema è che
nessuno lo sa quindi quando non lo
felice apre la porta
no no no no no il razzismo grezzo
e libri
e questo è solo la terza puntata
immagino solo cosa potrebbe accadere
nella 46esima iniziano a spararsi con la
polizia in una guerra tra gang
fatto sta che nonno felice rimarrà
sempre nei nostri cuori comprese queste
atrocità di sceneggiatura grazie gino
bramieri
e agile aggiunta agli highlights a gas
non ho fatto niente non ho fatto nulla
ahia volevo ringraziare il nord di vpn
per aver sponsorizzato questo video come
sapete non diviene vi protegge i dati
nelle reti pubbliche e poi se volete
fare anche voi a casa il drink in game
di nonno felice potete farlo
tranquillamente connettendovi l'oud ad
un ip italiano e in descrizione trovato
il codice scontro gli automi cosa volete
usare quello di chailly per lavoro di
dio